while I said to the gardens
thirty years but not a
day when she is forbidden from
hibernian of cerium and when it is
not a weekday for you
she would have told me how you
still have fun reading I do not understand
Sunday gives  at the word amusement the
meaning childishness of wasting time
my temper of yoni divided with françoise
while waiting during the rally she
announces to him that she had just seen
madame robin socrates pass him with the evening dress that
she had made at
châteaudun is far to go there before
she could do business sausset
maybe maybe what meant
maybe no said françoise so as not
to definitively rule out the
possibility of a more
favorable alternative hold 10th wait by
hitting the franc  it makes me think
that I did not know if she had
arrived at the church after the libation
I will have to think about asking her Françoise had the
dregs look at me this black cloud
behind the steeple this bad sun
on the  s slates of course that the day
will not pass without rain it was
not possible that it stays like that
it was too hot and the
sooner the better because until the storm
has broken mono de vichy ne
will not descend added ms. waits in
the minds of those who wish to buy
the descent l'eau de vichy import it
infinitely this the fear of seeing madam
copycat and her dress
maybe maybe is what when it
rains on  the place there is not much
shelter
how three o'clock suddenly shouting
my aunt alice is in then the
slope started I forgot my cape if
I start I understand now
why mono de vichy will remain on
the stomach and  rushing to a book
of mass or winger in
gold-mounted purple velvet and we in her head she
tries and escape from these images bordered
by a bale of lace of yellowed
center paper that marks
the pages of my aunt's whole  going to
launch costs started to read
the sacred texts as soon as possible
in intelligence ruins were slightly
on borrowed time in the old and or
whether taken that long after
gingham water pepsin would still be able
to catch up with it and make it leaving
three hours it's amazing the
weather this  that time passes a little
blow to the pane as if
something had carried it follows the example fall of the
giants like great sand known there
it fell from a window above the more
the fall these tendencies are regulated by
adopting  a rhythm becoming
universal innovative musical sound fluid
it was the rain and well françoise
what was I saying it was
falling but I think I heard the
bell on the garden door
go and see who is what can  to be
outside so much by and françoise was coming back
it's madame amédée my grandmother
who said she was going for a ride it's
raining hard though
it takes me 3 10 m to wait for
the front with my eyes to the sky
I've always said that  he did not have
the mind made as  everyone I
prefer it to be her than me that they
are in order at the moment madam
ahmadi it's always all the extreme of the
others said françoise the sweets
reserving only the moment when they
would be sol with the others  servants
to say that she thought my grandmother was a
bit offended here is the salvation a
year passed will not come great and my aunt
it will be there so much that will have scared her
but it is not healthy because Mrs
October it is only  four and a
half hours than 90 and I had to
pull up small curtains to have a
nasty toy department
at 4:30 a.m. eight days before the rogations to
my poor Françoise
painting must be biannual anger after us
too the world today  today in fact too much
as my cellphone says
we have forgotten it too much the good god and he
boasts of a bright redness to animate the cheeks
you hear me you know said a friend
unfortunately athens bless her
to be introduced one that françoise
returned is d  agree smile who has  the
purpose was to put herself
in unison with the joy that carole hallée did not doubt
that it was caused to my aunt
anti culan the pro sectors show that
despite the use of the live style she
brought back albon domestic the lyrics
at the same time had condescended to help the
visitor but structured will be delighted
delighted if madame octave does not rest
past the reception the priest
cannot disturb the priest is
downstairs I said to enter the room in
reality the visits of the priest  did
not make waiting for me as great a pleasure
as supposed Françoise and the
ruminations so she thought she had to
give up did not entirely respond
to the feelings of the patient the priest
excellent a man with whom I regret
not having dug more because if  we
heard nothing by chance
he knew a lot of technologies
accustomed to giving the distinguished
visitor information about the church
he even intended to write a
book on the pa  king of cambrai the
tired by the explanations in fact neither
is always the same but
when on arrival thus nor fair at the
same time as that of the binds his visit
from benin frankly unpleasant to my
aunt she liked him better to enjoy
of the rally and not having everyone at
the same time but she was not
lazy to see the priest effect it is
only a sign to cancel ali
2 because a person went at the
same time as him which lagardere is a
little alone  when they left,
priest, what did they
tell me that there is an artist who
set up his easel in your church
to copy a stained glass window
I mean that I arrived at my
age without ever having  heard
of such a thing
what is it that today's world is going
to look for
is what is most violent in
the church I will not go so far as  to say that
it is what there is more towards a body
stylet in saint-hilaire of the parties which
deserve to be visited
there are others who are well established
in my poor basilica the only one in the
whole diocese that has not even been
restored my
god thinks so and it is ancient but in
france acquired stopped in  main management
even passes for the state of mind of the
steres so personally I will
not give under but which are
placed on the connoisseurs
immediately after that of meaning I
recognize besides that beside
certain details a little realistic
it does not present others which testify
to a true spirit of observation
but when one does not come to speak to me about the
vitro it attracts common sense to leave
the windows which do not give day and
30 even the view by its reflections of  'a
color that I could not define in
a church where there are not two ladies
who are at the same level and who
refuse to replace me on the pretext
that these are the tombs of the years of
congress and lords  guermantes
of the old accounts debrabant the
old  s the direct ancestors of today's duke
of guermantes is also of
the chef's opinion since she is one of the
lost mistresses who married her
cousin from a grandmother who forced her to
lose interest in people who
ended up  by understanding all the names
each time we take
it's that she that of the duchess of
guermantes claimed that it must have been
at 42 madame deguitar and 6
everyone burst out laughing a death stamp
to defend themselves by arguing  a certain
letter to share I seemed to
remember that there were guermantes in
there and for once I was with the
others between them two being able to
allow that there took place
kelly kelly had a link between saint-  rémy
de pension is the descendant of geneviève
de brabant voignier feels live it
is no longer today that
farm carros although antiquity
although in antiquity the shea tree is
due to a boom due to trade and
felt hats and clocks i
am  not sure of the  equipment the sea
dogs a deal I would believe
will train him flying very willingly that
the first name tiff and hérouville
reducing hilarious like châteaux drôme
like châteauroux castro mrad life but
I will tell you about this right all this
but our faith and use it well
stained glass  superb almost all modern and
this imposing entrance of him philippe to
take and who would be better in his place
in cambrai even equivalent to the time the
famous back of chartres I
even saw yesterday the brother of doctor percepied
leaves nature and who look at her
when a more  beautiful work
but as I told him to this
artist who are the diola this very beautiful
lee who is apparently a real
virtuoso of the brush who find him
linear textures this stained glass which is
still a little bit darker than the
others